es que hoy se cumplen dos meses de la
llegada al poder en afganistán por parte
del grupo talibán entre la espada y la
pared por la falta de recursos en su
intento por el reconocimiento de la
comunidad internacional y en la búsqueda
de más ayuda se comprometieron a
garantizar los derechos de la mujer pero
no sólo bajo las reglas de la ley
islámica occidente ha criticado
constantemente al grupo talibán por no
cumplir sus promesas sobre el respeto a
los derechos de la mujer y también de
las minorías y por no incluir
suficientes miembros de otros grupos
étnicos a su gabinete además de todo
esto se suma la delicada situación de
seguridad en el país amenazado por
grupos terroristas internos y la
situación de vulnerabilidad y hambre de
más de un millón de niños nos acompaña
desde la ciudad de madrid' en españa
maría jesús vega portavoz de acnur en
ese país gracias a maría jesús por estar
con nosotros en directo américa en
francés 24 cuál es la situación de los
refugiados y desplazados afganos en este
momento
bueno la verdad que la situación es de
una gran incertidumbre de gran
inseguridad estamos ante una nueva
emergencia humanitaria de desplazamiento
dentro de afganistán porque la gran
mayoría de personas no han cruzado
fronteras que están prácticamente
cerradas sino que se han quedado dentro
son 18 millones de afganos y han camas
que necesitan asistencia humanitaria
para sobrevivir y tres millones y medio
de desplazados personas que han tenido
que dejar su casa sus hogares y todo lo
que todo lo que tenían para poder poner
a salvo su vida en otras zonas del país
este año
se han contabilizado como unas 660.000
personas que se han tenido que desplazar
80% son mujeres y niños vamos gente
inocente gente vulnerable que
infancias truncadas personas que no han
conocido otra cosa más que el
desplazamiento a lo largo de las últimas
décadas y bueno la supervivencia diaria
por sobrevivir una persona que vive en
maría jesús en constante sufrimiento
como 7 lo está pintando en este panorama
que vivo ahorita afganistán hablemos
precisamente de esa situación vamos a
hablar primero de las mujeres de los
derechos de las mujeres en ese país y
como lo comentábamos en nuestra crónica
de salud con mi compañera más romeros
también cómo es la situación sanitaria
de las mujeres de las trabajadoras de la
salud en afganistán
bueno el alto comisionado de naciones
unidas para refugiados clip ahora ni
estuvo en septiembre de viaje allí y
estuvo hablando con el gobierno interino
precisamente para bueno pues pedir que
se cumpla con esos compromisos que han
hecho públicos de respeto por derechos
humanos de regreso al trabajo de
personal femenino mujeres también
mujeres trabajadoras de acnur en en
algunas regiones y para asegurar esa
seguridad y esa atención a toda la
población permitiendo también el acceso
de organizaciones como acnur y muchas
otras que estamos presentes en el país
dando asistencia médica dando asistencia
psicológica tan necesaria para
muchísimas parte de la población que
está temerosa que están muchos de ellos
pues escondidos con con esa
incertidumbre de haber perdido además
sus puestos de trabajo en muchos casos y
de no tener siquiera bueno pues ese
poder adquisitivo para comprar comida
para atender a cosas médicas o para
comprar medicinas que son básicas con
las que aquí puedes curar cualquier cosa
y allí es muy difícil el poderlas
conseguir con el gobierno talibán en el
poder a dos meses hoy justamente de su
llegada a 15 de octubre es difícil para
ustedes prestar esta ayuda humanitaria
bueno
digamos que estamos operando en un
entorno de seguridad en un país en
conflicto hay un riesgo claro de
violaciones de derechos humanos al que
desde luego los trabajadores de acnur no
son ajenos formamos parte de esa foto
del país y evaluamos la situación en el
país la verdad es que día a día
la población bueno nos nos necesita
estamos dispuestos a quedarnos y
mantenernos a llevamos 40 años
trabajando en afganistán y allí vamos a
continuar mientras se nos dé la
oportunidad de acceder a la población
mientras haya un mínimo de condiciones
de seguridad y mientras podamos contar
con los fondos necesarios para poder
llevar a cabo estas operaciones puesto
que la ayuda escasea y son ingentes las
necesidades de esta población
no obstante
estamos llevando ayuda humanitaria
tenemos puentes aéreos organizados a
kabul
de pakistán en el este desde uzbekistán
en la zona norte también traslados en
avión traslados por por camión con
tiendas de campaña con paquetes
higiénicos sacos de dormir y cacerolas
para cocinar en fin todo tipo de
materiales que se necesitan como
respirar ahora mismo en el país hablemos
de esa ayuda humanitaria maría jesús
como hacen ustedes para garantizar que
esa ayuda realmente si le llega a las
personas digamos a lo mejor el dinero
ofrecido por la comunidad internacional
es 2 mil millones de euros ofrecidos por
la unión europea estos 300 millones de
dólares adicionales que ha ofrecido
también eeuu cómo hacer para que este
dinero no llegue a manos corruptas
bueno nosotros estamos incrementando
todo lo que son los procesos y los
procedimientos éticos
la revisión de organizaciones con las
que trabajamos codo a codo en en
afganistán para asegurar que la ayuda
humanitaria y que la atención se recibe
de manera igual en todas las partes del
país y que el criterio es vulnerabilidad
y población civil por encima de
cualquier otra consideración
es un poco la condición que estamos que
estamos poniendo así lo hemos trasladado
a las autoridades y en este momento
estamos trabajando en 34 en las 34
provincias de afganistán
más o menos en tres cuartas partes de
todas las municipalidades que hay en el
país y bueno pues vamos a hacer todo lo
posible por continuar llevando como digo
esa asistencia que es de supervivencia
en muchísimos casos en este momento a
personas de todas las etnias porque
sabemos que bueno
un crisol de etnias de grupos religiosos
tayikos uzbekos están los azar a
bastones de ari y no queremos que haya
ningún tipo de discriminación ni por
género ni por raza ni por ninguna otra
consideración